okay hi everyone this is a different
kind of meeting because what we're
looking at is some Wolfram Institute
work on a packlet for
hypergraph
well hypographs in general
and so
Nick was going to show how this works
and this is the first time I'm seeing
this
um
so there's a hypergraph object
Yeah so basically the idea is to show
some first of all it's the bucklet for
hypergraph so there is a typograph
object a typograph object contains some
edges and vertices
right some
um previous idea it automatically
renders like a graph does
yeah it's a like a first class citizen
it has a red border
house like graphs have like a some
purplish trees have greenish and
typographs are red okay for some reason
okay so one addition
to that theming you know the physics
project has traditionally been a purple
themed thing so we might consider that
but that's a um uh
well
graph is already purple I know I know I
know so let's see what purple it is
ah it's red and purple
well we should let the Design Group
maybe have a suggestion about this okay
um
all right so
that type of girl anyway is an ordered
hypograph
is that correct this actually is this
this is actually we are dealing with
unordered by default so one thing I'll
show a bit later that we have like an
additional annotation to each Edge this
is which is its Symmetry and by default
it's unordered
but actually you can show it now why not
right so we can annotate each Edge
by any symmetry I mean I I you know one
of the things that we learned in the
physics project is the value of having
ordered hypergraph
structures
I think covers can defend this position
more clearly because I was also kind of
against Unknown by default at first I
think it's a mistake I just think a list
is not unordered by default if we had a
set object that was unordered by default
I would be more inclined to say that
this is right but it's a list it's not
unordered
so let me jump in a second so
um the reason the reason why we want an
ordered by default I mean this is just a
choice there's no there's not so much of
a conceptual reference to an order or
order it's more that we need a control
on the symmetry of the edge very
explicitly so we could make them uh
ordered by default and then they are
like the hypographs in the physics
project there's no difference there I
mean it's just a matter of what is
default that's just an option but what
is different here is that we are giving
a very explicit treatment of symmetry we
we are I guess so it makes more sense to
have them unordered by default with no
Symmetry and then to say as The
annotation what symmetry you want to
have
um because because what we've got if you
remember you know how permutations work
for example
we can specify
a right yes exactly like that yeah
but I think what you said is exactly
what we have I think you say that we
they should be unordered by the I'm
sorry I'm sorry they should be they
should be by default they should have no
Symmetry by default
if you want them to have symmetry put in
a symmetry yeah yeah
the founder option no I understand but
but but but by no symmetry I mean that
one two three is equivalent to nothing
else
sure yeah yeah
okay this is the north symmetry because
it's ordered yeah and I'll and we
uh interpret or represent the Symmetry
by just a like generators for the
permutation group
fine but that's what I'm saying I think
it's a no-brainer thing that the default
should be that there isn't any Symmetry
and if you specify a symmetry great then
you have a symmetry yeah I mean here the
cultivate is simply whether you take
lists or you take multi-sets as your
default no but we have lists yeah lists
are the thing that all you know and plus
they turn out to have worked rather well
in the physics project so I think we
should you know we shouldn't go against
that yeah there's a minor thing it's a
minor it's just a choice that's an easy
thing to fix
um all right is it the right thing to
use an annotation
for the cemetery or is that actually
more of a serious construct I mean in
other words we don't have the notion of
a list you know in the language we don't
have the notion of a list with a certain
symmetry but we could have we certainly
have the notion of a structured array
with certain symmetry
foreign
symmetric and asymmetric
right so I think we should be using it
so go ahead
but here I don't know just much easier
for now just store every additional
concept that I call an option as an
annotation just model graphs as much as
possible it's like I support a bunch of
those annotations at that point so
that's the third Point by the way
Jonathan hello Jonathan you know do feel
free to jump in yeah sorry I tried
earlier but I think we moved on so it's
okay I'll jump in again if it's relevant
well did you want it did you want to
re-jump to whatever you were jumping to
before
uh I mean I just had a couple I mean I I
broadly agree that um if yeah
particularly if you're representing
symmetries as kind of
um uh subgroups of the permutation group
then it makes sense to have no group
structure as the default
um although to play Devil's Advocate a
little bit I do think there is something
inherently a bit weird about the fact
that you've got a nested list the
outermost listed is is orderless but the
innermost list is ordered by default
that's that's the one it's the strongest
defense like I can see for this for this
yeah right I mean we've had that issue
you know in in everything in the physics
project because we because we are
currently treating
sort of hyper edges as being a big vat
of hyper edgers and not an ordered
sequence of hyper edges
um that's what we've got right I mean so
yeah yeah I mean the only thing I can
add to that is that yeah so this is
exactly as Nick says this is a this is
precisely a problem that we run into
when doing tensor algebra so right now
for instance in the in the symbolic
representation of you know things like
rieman tensors and stuff
um
we yeah we essentially use the same
structure that you've got either a list
or a sparse array and then there's in
that case it's not an annotation but
it's just a kind of effectively a list
of slot symmetries and then you have to
do you know complicated Butler Portugal
how are the slot symmetries stored
uh so it's a list of rules
um so okay effectively what's going on
internally is it's modeled on what we
did for findable from a model proof uh
which you know this this is you know the
sort of hypograph theorem prover where
you say what's effectively going on you
you sort of algebraitize the whole thing
so that the you know the case of an
orderless
um hyper Edge or something is the case
where the composition operator on the
individual hypervertices is computer you
know has a commutativity property so you
reduce everything to some algebraic
axioms and then so in the case of the
tensor algebra stuff it's there's just a
list of algebraic axioms that say you
know what the Symmetry is the ring and
tensor are or whatever but how does I
should know this but how does a
structured array they we have symmetries
for structured arrays don't we next do
you know this
well I only know that you know for
symbolic tensors to say structure no I
mean no I just want to shown to
something symmetric
okay structure to it a different
structure straight but for symbolic
tensors and other special symmetries
like symmetric and symmetric you can use
right not but we need to know how those
are used because that shouldn't form
this because I mean be nice to be able
to say symmetric for you know
no that might be like for I was planning
to do something like this for a
representation for a different
representation right now we store edges
as this incidence list of edges right
like for graphs but for graphs there's
also multiple representations you can
store them as list of edges or you can
store them as an adjacency Matrix yep
and if I also implement this additional
representation as a hypermatics in this
case I can also annotate it with this
kind of
symmetries so but that's right that's
for the future we should let you go on
here okay so onward
all right so the focus of this packlet
overall is to to focus on more smaller
hyper graphs right it also supports what
I was going to mention like zero RIT
edges too
right and
and the result like because we focus on
the smaller a nice widget
yeah so you can draw a bunch of small
hybridges very easy to know there's a
nice widget for that yeah
again to a round one yeah it's a
different I mean just use the text font
the text font you don't want to use a
code font for that
or maybe because it's I think I use some
kind of Ideal queer I don't remember
don't use an absolute font just use the
text font and you'll be fine
I think
um well anyways probably a little bit of
detail in this that could be improved
but this is still very cool
yeah there's like a different modes of
drawing edges like you can do instead of
selecting and then pressing a button you
can
drag and drop them like this
and after you draw it you can click it
click copy it right now you have this
object
and so if I say input phone to that
medicine what happens if I take input
form of that object
right through the hyper edges at least
the vertices and a bunch of options
yeah yeah
sorry this is direct analog of what the
heck is that
it's a it's a traditional form
traditional form just showing the edges
like this
wait like it shows here this is the
truth
you're just sliding that by
that's a non-trivial and somewhat
interesting form
why is it the right form I mean so every
hyper Edge looks like a permutation or
something there but it doesn't it's not
really a permutation
I just replace I just replace list I
know I can see is that is that a
notation that anybody else uses for
hypographs
uh maybe so but I can I can comment
briefly that the so the the brackets I
think is just incidental there I I don't
think we ever made a strong choice about
that but the the use of the o plus
um it's actually operational because we
have hypograph addition and and it works
exactly as you should algebraically
without annotation so that's that's uh
that's cool I mean you could then think
of a graph as being uh you know some
kind of sum like that of pairs
absolutely that's that's right that's
right
and actually you can add exactly yeah
that's the point where you go like this
it's like a Direction but but that's you
know
the atom one is the same as in both
cases which is not obviously the right
thing how would I do that adding it as
two different typographs
where you know where for example the
eights are in common but the other the
other vertices are not no then this has
to be implemented some disjoint Union
thing we don't have a function for them
but it's going to be a typographic
disjointed Union or something yeah
basically yeah it operates like like you
expect Stephen it operates that um the
common vertices are sort of multi-edge
uh addition yeah I see it right yeah and
the spare ones are are sort of partial
addition over yeah
let's just write out for a second for a
graph written out as an edge list could
you just just do this for a second just
make a random graph
that's very small random cough well I
don't know
okay fine all right now uh let's let's
give the edge list okay
so
right so if I say join that thing to
itself then I'll just get double edges
no
okay
fine
okay so that's the same thing that
you're doing that's fine okay I get it
yeah
and maybe maybe Nick it's a good point
to comment on the embedding that is just
temporary at the moment we're using some
graph embedding of the projected down
hypograph yeah I'm still using graphene
underneath nothing nothing fancy I just
also add some
dummy edges so that it looks like this
the white curved yeah that's cute
that it works with multi-edges down
below yeah yeah I I I I I want to
comment that the intention is the ones
that look
um
um come back right where uh sorry
concave the ones that look like spider
web that's kind of the intention so that
you can have the lower order stuff not
get in the way of the higher order stuff
and so visually helpful but at the
moment it's just using the embedding so
some of them are concave and some of
them are convection modelers randomly uh
but eventually we want to do our own
embedding function for hypographs so the
way we're thinking is we're gonna take
hyper edges so that it's it's cheaper uh
we're gonna take hyper edges to be
always uh contained in a plane in
principle and then we're gonna we're
just going to orient the planes uh to to
to display the list intersection and
things like that eventually what did we
do I mean so max had a whole way of
doing
uh hypergraph visualization particularly
in 3D do I mean Max we've spent a long
time doing
well I I know you have 3D I'm but do you
understand what Max did
well for the 3D case we spent a long
long time talking about we had a whole
crazy scheme maybe Jonathan remembers we
had a whole crazy scheme with a bunch of
optimizations it was it was generalized
spring electrical it was ultimately what
it boiled down to yeah
but there was another thing for for the
surfaces right so it was spring
electrical with surface tension so the
idea was you you had you had spring
forces between hyper edges that's right
between hyper vertices you had
electrical and you had electrical
repulsion and then within an individual
hyper Edge you would have a kind of
surface tension force that would try and
minimize its area
okay
and is that different from what you're
planning Nick
or is that similar to what you're
planning oh I'm not sure right now I'm
doing something similar for each Edge I
also introduced some dummy vertex when
they and then I just if I use graphing
padding with some screen electrical it
also would like introduce some tension
or whatever
right yeah I just
right if you introduce enough additional
edges you've got a whole surface there
I mean if you had essentially a
triangulation of additional edges that
would be like an approximation to a
surface
you're introducing a single dummy vertex
but in principle I I think these look
really nice at least at these sizes they
introduce a single vertex which H and I
also put like directed edges in both
directions so that they curve and then I
extract the H in variant also and drop
one of them
that is a hat but it's cool yeah no yeah
and for the 3D I also apply
because field curve is not longer works
for the 3D case I also apply some
surface minimization there why this
filter a few steps
I think it doesn't work for 3D so it's
kind of annoying so it's like a polygon
and then I do some surface minimization
so that it actually can we should we
should merge a little bit ask a question
about filter we can ask
uh yeah
okay
all right
sorry onward
now rules are the most interesting
things rewriting
all right so I have a few examples so
the rules now are also first class
citizens now they have blue border
they basically represented by input and
output hypergraphs so you can construct
a rule by just its input form is like a
input hypergraph and an output
typographic like this
and the variables here are just
numerical things I mean there's no like
in in writing in the physics project we
tended to use X and Y and things but
they you could you have any symbols or
any Expressions yeah I'll go we'll go to
there so here is like left hand side the
hypograph is unlabeled right so it's
basically an unordered age
so it can orderlessly match against this
one in all possible cases in all
possible ways and
and because it's not unlabeled get to it
a little bit later basically for this
easiest examples first you know this can
match against this one in three possible
ways
you may say that you can construct this
Edge in frequency again so basically
applying a rule to hyper graph just
produces a bunch of informations in in
the association like an output
hypergraph and some meta information
that you can use maybe some for
causality later
right so because it's now it's just not
just like for the roofer model cases or
just a list of edges
but also some vertices you can rules can
also introduce new vertices and just
three vertices without any edges so
remove vertices from the hydrograph as a
part of your writing so in this case
there's no new vertices in no delete it
vertices but if there are priorities
it's like this here that wasn't part of
the left hand side
something more interesting could happen
but I mean a standard physics project
rule can create new vertices right
well only Raptor erupting in an edge it
can be it can create like three vertices
because there's no there wasn't an idea
of a hypergraph as a some just like a
graph
with no edges for example but a single
vertex right
you wouldn't make this with a typography
how is a free vertex different to uh to
a hyper edge with a single element
well it is different because why
writing a little bit differently yo
right you can
it depends on your application but if
you generalize enough you have ages from
zero rot to and rtn and vertices you can
you can put edges around vertices but
you also can have three vertices
can can you can you give an example of
an application area where that's a
useful distinction
well I don't have to like come up with
it I'm just compared to the graphs and
there's no reason
to exclude for the for the hypergraphy
graphs can no but I think one of the
things that's nice about hyper graphs is
that sort of everything is wrapped
together it's just a hyper Edge yes so
we if I can jump in uh we did we have
had a few philosophical discussions
about this and and it's it's something
that that we are we're actively thinking
so um I actually I agree that we I mean
a one Edge vertex are somehow
conceptually similar so actually my view
and what is behind the philosophy of how
we've designed this backlit so far is
that vertices are somehow you know some
some kind of substrate where your
hypergraphs are going to live and and
the hypercraft data is actually Edge
data so unary Edge binary Etc right so
um the principle here is that as
Jonathan says um we should be treating
one Edge as effectively as as vertex
information so that's why we're treating
independent free vertices as
uninteresting or we're sort of
dismissing that case explicitly unless
they carry Edge information right that's
kind of an idea
my opinion on this would be simply that
a graph is a special case of a
hypergraph where the hyper edges are of
arity at most too and that so that
encompasses that means that you
Encompass the the distinction between
the vertex uh set and the edge set as a
special case
so one one example in which
um this this is relevant there are two
examples in which this this might might
get relevant one is
um multi-multi edges right where you
want to keep track of multiplicities and
the other is where you where you're
doing something like categorical
diagrams uh rewriting and then your your
objects or one morphisms are somehow you
know distinguishable or not
distinguishable that those are the kind
of contexts where you might care about
this I thought okay wait a minute in in
the generalization of category Theory
well okay somebody who knows much more
about this like Jonathan probably
does I mean I bet category Theory
generalizes so it isn't just objects
amorphisms zero and one well yes and
there are many possible generalizations
but one of the most notable features of
category theory is that you don't need
to have a distinguished object set right
because because every object has an
Associated identity morphism if you just
know the homset if you just know the set
of a class of morphisms you can
reconstruct the class of objects and I
think that that's really the question
here right so
um with a graph currently if you just
know the edge set it is not possible to
reconstruct the vertex set now in my
opinion it's not clear that has to be a
fundamental design feature as I say it's
possible that you could treat
freestanding vertices as you know as as
hyper edges with just a single vertex in
them and that would extend to the hyper
into the hypograph case beautifully and
that would be more like the category
Theory case that you know the idea again
the idea being you can always
reconstruct the objects from the whole
from the from here yeah so I I
completely agree with that Jonathan I
think what's Happening Here is more the
implementation that we're doing right
now treats vertices as as this substrate
somehow and then if we were if we were
to do things that involve sort of single
vertex rules then we would put a one
Edge on them to make it to make to make
it explicit right so at the moment for
example I'll show some examples in a bit
where we live uh a naked vertex floating
specifically to somehow represent that
we are rewriting away but we're keeping
the the context information in this sort
of double push-out rewriting sort of
language for those familiar with it
yeah I my intuition is that this is not
a necessary distinction but we shall see
well for problematic perspective it's
still useful right it's like in this
example this trivia text can match
against three
uh vertices to the part of an edge if
you represent it as a ornery Edge
instead you have to like wrap your hyper
graph the those it's just decorate it
with little edges yeah it's like it may
be as general as it is but if you just
hold on that's generally writing as
possible why not
well I mean the reason we're seeing this
issue is because we only have the notion
of edges we don't have the notion now
our edges are just you know lists of of
vertices we could also have a much more
deeply nested structure to represent
each Edge
and then we wouldn't have the same quite
the same story
so I'm saying I mean we're making a
right now our Edge is a bucket of
vertices
but it could also be a nested tree of
vertices and so on just you know it
could have structure in the very
structure of the edge
yeah that's the
that's three times uh the Symmetry tags
that we that we have the the edges
themselves will carry some some kind of
structure
they could have an any structure in
general could be an expression of any
kind yes but in general that's not what
we're doing here
um
I mean what what you've just invented
there is expression trees right if you
if you allow a hypograph with arbitrary
nesting you get an expression tree yeah
yeah but which and there's a you know
that's the thing
who was looking at that UTI was looking
at that
um looking at uh uh kind of compiling
everything to hypergraphs right
well I I was doing that thing which he
was working with some specific machines
like find it oh that's right yeah yeah
okay so what did you conclude from that
Nick
expression trees you can do rewriting
arbitrary expression trees
to hypergraphs
and because we're doing in the blue form
language because we are doing a writing
with the expression trees you can form
you can turn any rewriting rule on those
to hypograph your writing
okay maybe again and that's how my
that's how my multi computational
backlit worked
by turning usual rewriting rules to
hypergraph rules right except it's not
actually in past tense it's actually in
the future tense because it's a packlet
that I know you worked on and I think
needs more you know needs to yeah it
needs a future
yeah okay fine it sounds thing
um all right let's keep going here so I
think I think I more or less understand
this
Okay so
that's the kind of motivation for free
vertices here writing
a bit more when you can swap them around
okay
well a bit more examples there's like a
highlight rule yeah highlight a rule
function there is in the packet that
also shows what happened
during the writing in a more explicit
way
well similar how we had in the set
replace function right before model so
what what H was matched and what was
created there again and annotated with
some red dashed things around yeah
that's not exciting in this case because
everything got red
but if we had a more complicated
hypograph there yeah like here because
it can match either against this age or
this age right it's either this one
turns red this one turns red
yeah
okay hang on so I I'm I'm sorry to take
the discussion back one step but
um on the on the freestanding on the on
the free floating vertex rewriting thing
yeah okay I think the thing I'm
objecting to there is that it seems like
if that if you're going to go for that
generalization then that is
insufficiently General because it seems
to me that if the if you if you wanted
to be the case that you can specify you
know I can rewrite this freestanding
vertex to say this Edge or this hyper
Edge
um and then and that you know that acts
within an existing hyper Edge you know
so like that vertex acts on vertex one
in that in that hyper Edge on the green
hyper Edge on the right
then shouldn't you also be able to
define a rule that says that specifies
you know that partially specifies a
hyper Edge so for instance it says
um you know I I I've got a rule that's
acting on ternary hyper edges but what
it does is it it rewrites say vertex one
and two to something else
if if you see what I mean
sorry sorry could you could you I'm not
sure so so okay so so right now what
you've got is a rule that allows you to
say you know I I can do rewriting of an
individual vertex to something right so
if we take that if we take that ternary
hyper Edge there the the one two three
hyper Edge in in light green on this one
yeah so so then then you you know you
for instance that rule could match say
vertex one and it could rewrite vertex
one into something right as it does that
yeah yeah okay but
if we're going to allow that
generalization
um which which is which I agree is a
strict generalization of what we did in
the physics project then what then do we
have an argument for not also allowing
the generalization that says I can I can
take vertices one and two in that hyper
Edge and rewrite those to something so
in other words I can take any subset of
a hyper Edge and rewrite that to
something why is it why are we only
allowing rewriting of single elements we
can do yeah
that's a good question hang on let me
let me figure this out well I guess I
mean ultimately depends on the Symmetry
right the you know you okay so suppose
you suppose you had a you suppose you
had a one two three hyper edge with a
cyclic symmetry then you could imagine
wanting to say it you know um I want to
rewrite the pair one two but not the
pair two one or something yeah we we
keep track of that with this so you can
you can do it with labels yeah with the
labels we we keep track of that
those are like three vertices they don't
have any Symmetry by itself because it's
an edge right yeah and they can match
like in any subset of vertices on the
right hand side anywhere right right
okay but so you're right that they don't
have symmetries but but you know for
instance could what if I wanted to say
specify a binary Edge you know one two
and I want and I want that to rewrite
versus these one two in that ternary
edge in that ternary hyper Edge are you
saying I would do that with using labels
no but no and you would have to include
you have too much in the input right
if you want like yeah you you have to do
something like
um what what draw some stuff
great
so you have
you have an edge right you want to match
against the journey one right exactly
you have to make an additional Edge
otherwise if it's a binary Edge it's
never going to match eternally one a
part of a Turner one but but then why do
we allow a single vertex to match right
because it's not an edge
it's like a it's a it's an exception
that we do for free vertices that's it
if you're going to allow that
generalization then surely you need to
go all the way no wait wait and they
subset to match any subset wait yes I
think I think it was kind of different
Nick I think I think that what Jonathan
is asking here
um if you were to match that to a
ternary edge I would I would simply
include the ternary edge in the input
right so so that's part of the part of
the magic so you have to find the
ternary edge and the binary Edge and
then you rewrite whatever you want and
it's going to find the subsets as you
say
right but you have to specify the
context of of the ternary edge that's
going to be preserved in the in the
rewriting
but what Jonathan well I don't know I
think John what Jonathan asks is for if
I have a left hand side that just
consists of a binary Edge like this one
yeah Jonathan says it should generalize
to matching against like part of the
tournament exactly right right you're
allowing for rewriting for your rewrites
to match individual elements of a hyper
Edge as well as the whole hyper Edge
I see I see I see I see that I see the
question I think the change in
perspective here is that we are not
considering like as as you pointed out
earlier we can have arbitrary structures
as edges basically so the the structures
of inside the edge we can really look
into inside the edge it's like we you
have to we're taking this perspective
we're not really looking into the unless
it's necessary for some computation or
some procedure and the edges are taking
as a whole with their with their order
and their symmetry tag right and so if
you want to specify a part of it then
you have to do some algorithm and then
Define new edges and then use those
edges to to do whatever procedure you
want but in at the rewrite level we are
only dealing with the hyper ridges as
primitive elements in a in the hypograph
object I I'm totally with you on that
and that would be the that's the wpp
approach but then that's I would argue
that's logically mutually exclusive with
allowing rewriting on individual
vertices isn't it if you're saying the
hyper edges are the first class citizens
then you can't drill down and extract
individual vertices to do rewriting of
them well I mean the thing here is that
we are doing rewriting over hypograph
objects and and the object carries
vertices and edges as separate entities
right I mean it's mostly in the
implementation it's not so much the
mathematical request I don't think I I'm
not convinced but let's keep going
because we don't need to get hung up on
this particular issue yeah I just want
to add like one intuition that they have
so that the reaction should be intuitive
in some way if I see the binary Edge on
my left hand side and there is no binary
edges on my target hypergraph it
shouldn't match you know very much but
when I see an input free vertex on the
left hand side and a bunch of vertices
why they gain the match right just
visually so it's it's a questionable
point of view right I agree yeah I agree
I agree where they are one edges yeah
let's keep going because I think it will
all become a bit clearer when we see
what all the various operations are yeah
yeah
here now
some examples with labels because the
way we have labels on the vertices also
have some semantic meaning when you do
the writing okay so by default there's
if this example if this is hyper age
is not
doesn't have any labels on it right
it applies in all possible ways on this
one
it's just a display thing it's not
really changing well photograph is but
here you actually have some meaning
especially when it's on the left hand
side of your rule wait wait wait wait
wait vertex labels a display function
piece of functionality means something
for the graph
that's weird it it means something when
you use them in your rules okay and how
it is used and maybe
gonna be explained in a minute yeah we
might we might need to I I'm actually
I'm also of the opinion that putting it
in the labels was a little bit you know
unstable in my opinion but I mean this
is I think for the sake of demonstration
of the purpose I think is is interesting
and and then maybe we have to put it in
the in another part of the object I
think naked reads right maybe oh you you
can look at it as an experimental
feature okay yeah yeah yeah labels in
the rules yeah just just to make sure
that I understand what's going on here
can I if we make the analogy to
expression rewriting can I think of this
as being the definition of constants as
opposed to sort of Quantified variables
yeah basically it's not actually it's
it's more it depends what you use as a
label so you can actually also use
patterns and labels then they're going
to be used as disjoint variables so we
have this special rule that if you have
variables and labels we just gather them
all together and say okay all the labels
should be this all the patterns all the
variables and labels should be distinct
yeah except that if two okay what you're
saying is which is a horrible situation
but one that we have seen before we saw
in the math mathematics project
two x's are the same but two x blanks
are different
is that correct
yes
in a way labels uh help would help us to
mitigate this issue exactly yeah because
we're imposing this additional condition
that when
we actually have like X and Y labels
as opposed to just using it from the
vertex names with the convention that a
literal vertex name is is I mean
somehow
there's a sort of indistinguishable
particle I don't know what is the what
is the analogy is there a physics
analogy two x's are just the same X but
two x blanks are distinct X blanks
in this context
what's going on is that we as I said we
the vertices themselves are just some
kind of background and you're putting
your information your your labels on top
is really what tells you what the data
should be and again I I agree that this
is conceptually indistinguishable from
doing one edges and it might well be
that we want to go super homogeneous and
just do one edges but that's that's kind
of the idea that you know you want to
express x and x two copies of the same
thing two identical electrons but they
are in sort of two different points of
space so they want they want to live on
different vertices so at the level of
the encoding in the language they
actually have to live on one and two as
as you know uh infrastructure
to just have a Multiplicity
to say we want to match x and x but we
could but they but you know but with
with strict multiplicity too or
something I mean that can be a that can
be an application but I feel that it's
more General especially when you're
doing better matching as we are
um to keep things as separate as
possible and if you want to do
multiplicity you can always do it after
the fact right
hmm okay
let's keep going the
well maybe a few of these examples
because I think
or we can just go
uh I might show you some of the some of
the symbolic examples because all I did
was basically
um do an application of the hyper
gravity right backlit which is to do
sort of compositional algebra like
categories and things like that
um and it's one it was one of the
projects that we were doing at The
Institute to try and formalize several
symbolic algebraic systems and purely in
terms of rewriting and now we we have
the sort of demonstration that it
already works it's I mean it has many
things to tweak and to improve but it's
working so let me just understand what
this is this is a multi-way system of
some kind
what is it yeah that's uh we just
applying the writing that we just tried
to describe on this specific hypograph
which is the same hip Powers has a much
more I can I mean that's going to be
part of my maybe I can I can go a bit
more incremental and it will be clear
what we're doing well let's just show
this one because it has some sure maybe
it's styles
up different from yours right
so here is just a it shows a bunch of
things so that there's a patterns so the
labeled ages are also being propagated
so that the actual labels are in data I
think I have some
leakage symbols again
there
uh
where is it
oh that's right it shouldn't be there
I can start mine if you want there's I
have in my skin yeah
anyway
so it's just a mutual system of
rewriting as usual
without constructed is there is there a
merging well we can do contraction
yeah but that has to take care of labels
and and some criteria which means that
you have right now in what you drew so
far
you do not have hypogov
isomorphism hypograph canonicalization
it's just
there is but they are technically
different because they are differently
labeled
you can do kind of different things with
it right I see okay you can turn them
into some canonical graph and just edges
maybe yes
these things are always amorphic so they
get contracted into one and this one
exactly okay that's how we do it
so
so should we see Carlos's stuff let me
show you I just I'll just brush a few
examples
um which are of the same kind
so let me share screen one and everyone
see that
yep okay so I mean this is not a dark
mode person yeah
I like it that's a Blackboard sort of
computational Blackboard healing
um so so yeah so basically uh
traditional category composition so
tumorphisms FG composed to have compost
G and so if you want to for example
check associativity this I think is one
of the main applications of this packlet
that I had the intention to develop is
to see algebraic axioms as emergent from
rewrite property from direct properties
of the system and so in this case you
take this initial State and you apply
the rule and sure enough you you get
this multi-way I mean this is these two
final states are actually isomorphic but
the labels are different and that's what
has the algebraic information so you
have the associativity Axiom there in
that in that hold on hold on hold on
hold on slow down I'm not fast enough
for this could you could you go back up
to the top yes okay so let's do
commutativity first you had the first
picture which was computer typically is
that right no no this first picture this
is this is simply defining an operation
right so this is is defining what it
means to compose to to morphisms two
arrows right FG ABC and then you've got
to make a composed morphism there
exactly so this is one example by the
way in which you you you use this
dangling vertices without edges as sort
of contextual information that is
relevant for for the system
um so okay so yes so then you you choose
your your initial State carefully and
you could choose a longer chain if you
want but this is sort of the minimal
case that shows some Behavior some
algebraic behavior and then then you
have ABCD and and so three morphisms in
a chain right and so you basically just
apply
um uh the the rule the composition rule
to this so you can apply either to FG to
get FG on the on the right or the HG so
you get GH on the left and then you
apply again because again it's it's the
same pattern and you get a single Arrow
from a to d but one is labeled by F
brackets yes and the other is right so
so so that so the idea that this is at
the level of hypergraphs unlabeled is
confluent has some algebraic meaning
that's the entire sort of takeaway of
the story which is the cool feature that
I would like to you know create for the
mathematical communities like trying to
replace action this is going back to the
suboxomatic or pre-aximatic sort of
approach where you replace enforcing
Axis or listing them or enumerating them
with simply spotting some rewriting
behavior of the if you if your system is
clever enough in this case it keeps
track of labels and all these kind of
bits business that we've been we've been
showing okay so hold on hold on hold on
hold on hold on so now algebraic
equivalence
becomes basically you say that those two
graphs are equivalent
although they're labels they're sort of
algebraic labels are different and
therefore you conclude there is an
algebraic equivalence that you deduce
from the equivalence of the graphs
correct basically
basically yeah so you can stay
in a very precise terms
terms simple hypograph right this
meaning there's no multiple and then you
level out the the labels you ended up
with a multi-hypergraph because that's
actually confluent but it has you know
if you're doing additive rewritings you
have two edges between A and B so you
that way that multiplicity allows you to
spot so the condition is like okay there
might be a non-trivial state algebraic
statement here and I say non-trivial
because there are times where there's an
algebraic statement where it's rather
trivial in and that doesn't give you
some interesting action like
associativity we find some actions so
let me just if this idea is clear I'll
show several examples because they are
basically the same right
um so the next the next is identity
identity arrows right and this is again
using the single element again could be
a one Edge could be a Vertex doesn't
matter too much uh so what it does is
you know takes the vertex and creates a
duplicate of of the vertex and then the
identity I work so sure enough you take
some example you you have this and you
know y and x and it creates x x here on
the on the right and it creates y y here
on the left so this is just an example
now
um
another so I want to show the
interaction of okay so this is going to
show the interaction of two such rules
so in this case
um in this case the dagger is just
flipping the the orientation of the
morphism right so if you take just a
normal V pattern so FG right ABC
um then you can apply both composition
and Dagger right this is the usual
exercise that people learning categories
do uh and you apply it in all possible
ways right so you first compose FNG and
you know if you are on the leftmost side
you're just leaving composition line in
some sense and then you apply some some
daggers here so the idea is that you
know here in this second state you you
spot uh a AC with a with the morphism in
the right direction and be standing
alone and you spot that here down as
well right so in the bottom in the
bottom right
um and there you spot the involativity
property of uh of the of the dagger this
anti-homomomorphism property that
basically says that you know Dagger of
FD is D Digger F dagger right yep again
we're the same with the same again so
another example and this is the sort of
the the only example that I've
discovered properly with this method
with this approach this is the first
time that we can do it computationally
but just by hand I discovered this case
uh a year ago or so is this is this uh
was technically called a semi-hepoid so
there's two ways to encode a semi-keeper
you can do it either with arrows or with
triangles or in fact higher order stuff
as long as you have two two sizes uh so
with arrows you basically have a diagram
so now this is the rewrite rule so the
diagram is you know arrow in one
direction arrow in the opposite
direction and then arrow in the other
direction so it's basically this
non-circulating and sort of the
dominating Direction wins and you get a
composition fgh from beginning to end
right
um so if you take your clever initial
state that has this the shape to say
it's basically a chaining and
alternating chain of arrows and you
apply that to to this what you end up is
sure enough
um you you have three hits
in this in this chain of the rule and
then those three hits produce again
three arrows that are hits and then
eventually you end up with a single
graph between one and six and then
what's interesting is that you have one
one expression one algebraic expression
that derives from it which looks like
associativity you're moving the bracket
around because these things are
sequentially ordered but when you go in
the middle precisely because there's
this flip of the arrow there's this
Twist of the of the elements in the
associativity property that was
identified in the 50s as something
called a heap and it has its own
algebraic history and it's quite a quite
a weird algebraic ternary algebraic
structure that was not anyway same
pattern hold on hold on hold on hold on
hold on hold on hold on so you know in
standard
uh uh sort of equational style axioms
you know I could write down some you
know we got a whole collection of them
in in the language for example of these
uh collections of equivalences
so are you saying that any such
equivalence can be compiled into a graph
rewriting uh into something like for
example let's say well you know like
like I have this you know minimal action
for Boolean algebra are you saying that
there is a graph rewriting that is
equivalent to that minimal Axiom my my
feeling is that that's true but I don't
I haven't proved it and I don't I don't
know so if that's the case just so I
understand in in the usual way
you know there's a law of inference that
allows you to go from one sort of
equational statement to another
and that law of inference has you know
you'll have a multi-way graph based on
applying those you know applying
using law of inference in lots of
different possible ways
that will get you
a collection of equivalent
Expressions but in other words if you
well it's it's right you're
it's a slightly different point of view
because the the equational it also can
also be seen as rewriting and
manipulating Expressions but but this
this is somehow deeper in in sort of
closer to the machine code or some some
sort of way where you're somehow just
letting the system do its thing and if
you're interested in recovering
algebraic information and equational
information like we are used to as
mathematicians
um then then you can spot for just
rewriting properties of the system in
this case this Confluence where there's
multiplicity and you might have
different labelings and the labelings
the actual information the algebraic
information is actually in the labeling
not so much in the writing the rewriting
is just it's doing what it's doing right
it's it has a life okay so what you're
saying is
in this case the emergence of inequality
yeah is a consequence of Confluence
correct there will be no equality
without Confluence that's that's right
that's right
and and what
and the things that the algebraist is
paying attention to are merely the
labelings correct
what's being go ahead
can I interrupt at this point so
uh so first of all the answer to your
previous question is yes uh your the
minimal action for Boolean algebra could
be represented in this way uh because
all that's being done here is
effectively just manipulation I mean
these this is just an operationalization
of the concept of commutative diagrams
so the the point is actually there's no
need for multi-way structure you can do
exactly the same thing with a single way
system you know so if you go back to the
uh to the associativity example what's
really happening is so these happen to
be destructive rights or you know
destructive rewrites and that's why you
need a multi-way system but if you if
you did the non-destructive case so if
you had a rule that said you know if
you've got uh you know what one Edge
that goes from X to Y one Edge that goes
from y to Z and you replace that not you
don't do a replacement but you you just
add an additional text to Z that now
you've got a rewriting rule that
effectively operationalizes the the
property of the operation of taking a a
transitive closure and then the
condition that all multi-edges in that
graph are equivalent is the statement of
the course bonding diagram commutes and
there's a universality theorem that says
any uh you know any algebraic equation
can be represented as a commutative
diagram
okay hold on hold on hold on hold on
hold on
so the multiple pieces here that I'm not
very adequately familiar with
so Jonathan can you okay
commutative diagram is you've got a
bunch of morphisms and you've got
I mean it's the state
walk me through how this works the point
is in a commutative diagram all you're
saying when you say that a diagram
commutes is effectively that all path if
you take uh any pair of edges all paths
between those edges are equivalent you
know yield equivalent morphisms on
composition yes I mean between those
edges or between those vertices between
those vertices okay sorry yeah
um all paths between those vertices so
that is a a general sort of category
Theory kind of thing that you've got
these two
well actually it's not yeah you've got
these two objects and you've got
morphisms that go from one to the other
and they're different ways to they're
kind of different sequences of morphisms
that get you from one to the other but
since you're going from the same object
to the same object that means that those
different morphism paths must somehow be
equivalent is that right right exactly
that's right yeah
um and and so the point is that yeah and
anything that you can so all I mean this
is this is actually how this is how
categorical Works internally right so
it's all just graphy writing underneath
or you know any any commutative diagram
can be constructed from some Elementary
graphic writing Rule and as I say you
don't actually need a multi-way
structure you can do everything with a
single way system
um because of Confluence guarantee it's
not like uh you know other kinds of
things
um and then the point is that that
anything you would represent with a you
know of the um the algebraic axioms that
you derive from a commutative diagram
you can then compute in a directly
algorithmic Way by just saying well you
know show me all you know compute the
transitive closure
show me all of the multi-edges and then
let me just make an equivalence between
all pairs of multiplication
um and I mean I can show an example in
categorical how this works in a second
but it's yeah no okay but I I understand
this so I mean that's that's basically
that's what's going on and so and so the
point is so so long as your rule for how
morphisms can be composed
um or how morphisms can be can be
generated from the underlying quiver as
long as as long as those rules can be
General enough you can represent any
algebraic theory in that way including
you know accidentizations of Boolean
algebra
yeah
yeah okay but the way that you
would lay down those axioms
so I mean your initial picture here yes
what would what would that conceivably
look like for a non-trivial
I'm confused how you encode
I mean the Axiom is an equivalence
between one algebraic object and another
right right and so in in the scheme that
I'm that I was describing there in the
sort of commutative diagram scheme you
would have a rewriting rule that just
that introduces new edges to this in
accordance with some Rubble I mean so in
this case it would be you know if you've
got a if you've got an edge that goes
from X to Y and you've got as you goes
from y to Z you replace it with one of
those from X to Z that would be the case
so that's like that you know that's the
that's the applying transitivity thing
um and then you just apply that rule
everywhere it applies until you reach a
fixed point and then once you reach that
fixed point you just apply equivalences
between all of them you know between all
the multi-edges
what's that
so I just made with I think Jonathan is
describing right so you you're adding
you're adding the edges
um I think exactly so if you apply that
rule now to that thing
uh
you don't want it to complete multi-way
structure because the the using a
multi-wear system is just going to
complicate things but you'll see that
some some nasty error
I think there's some memory that was uh
yeah you have a assigned I think yeah
that's my phone
let me call it x y z
you just clearly oh yeah
I'm using a capital D is such a
disastrous idea but anyway
what happened there
oh okay all right so now let's interpret
this so you'll see there are a bunch of
multi-edges that have appeared and so
the point is if you if you run this
system until you reach your fixed point
and then you just impose equivalences
between all multi-edges that corresponds
to the statement that the original
diagram commuted
I understand I'm trying to I'm trying to
just work out how does this relate to
sort of the entailment cone stuff
Nick might understand from the matter
mathematics project or maybe Jonathan
also understand maybe you all understand
this
um
how does that I mean this is like making
an entailment cone isn't it but it's
just doing it in a slightly different
way
yeah it's a in some sense it's sort of
like hands-off that you specify you
specify the compositional rules
um and you let the system evolve let me
make a comment on that I mean you know
to me substitution is a very natural
thing to do with a symbolic expression
okay yeah but it is realistically at
some level of meta logic
in other words I think none of these
things it's like modelist models I think
nothing gets away without having some
meta logic you can argue it's your
metallogic is more natural than some
other metallogic but I think you always
have to have something
or am I wrong
I I think I don't know if this answers
your not your question directly now but
your comment earlier but the picture
that that you have in mind by the way
which is the title of this thing chemoid
weird word is that instead of so a
category is an example of a chemoid
because you have you from the
perspective of that Jonathan was saying
that you have like a quiver you
basically have a bunch of rules that
tell you what to do and in this case of
a category simply you compose like this
and you have units like like this at the
bottom right and then it's more about
okay now I have to specify my initial
States and there are many perspectives
you can take you can take the community
diagram perspective where you can take
the sort of pure rewrite perspective or
just set theoretical perspective with
source and Target maps and all that kind
of stuff but at the end of the day once
you specify those two those two pieces
of information the the rest sort of
follows right and and the question is
how do you encode the conditions that
you impose on how those operations work
and traditionally you would impose
something like a social DVD and in many
usual presentations of categories here
they would literally state it like in an
algebraic theory that said you know
whenever you have this situation you
have to equate these two things but with
different perspective you get the
formulation so this is not something
completely you know revolutionary it's
just saying there's a there's a much
more
um rewrite uh rewrite sure which is very
interesting yeah I'm just trying to I'm
just trying to push back on the idea
that there is something I mean there are
multiple ways to do sort of natural
seeming rewrites for example I think
substitution is a very nice structural
way to do it what you're providing here
is something
that is I'm still trying to wrap my head
around exactly what's going on here I
mean
go scroll down for a second can you can
you get to a fixed point there
did you reach your fixed point if you if
you evolved for another step will you
get to a fixed point
I think it's going to keep on adding
multi-edges because it's gonna spot the
pattern over and over again so it's
gonna so will it ever reach the fixed
point not not explicitly in this case
certainly moving it right it doesn't
remove the pattern so right yeah so so
but it will reach a point where it's no
longer connecting vertices that were
previously unconnected which is I think
I think that matters so if you take
those hypergraphs and
you hell if you run something like this
you can
just with an old cut graph revising code
Carlos yep
whoops
well part of the matter but okay what
did that just do
is that where you want to see uh okay
maybe do states plots list if you want
the if you want the diagrammatic
representation
in the in the last argument yeah so the
property at the end
list
sorry
by the way that those those um
uh shadowing messages it would be nice
to
somehow avoid that anyway okay fine so
this is exactly this is structurally
what's happening right so you you've got
three morphisms laid out end to end I've
got a rule there that just you know
anytime you've got two of them that
share a domain and a co-domain you just
add a new Edge between them a new
morphism between them so now you end up
with a bunch of multi-edges and then the
statement of associativity is this is
the statement that all those multi edges
are the same in some sense yeah
um so right so this becomes a complete
typograph in some sense
up at some point it becomes a complete
hypograph and then you can read off from
getting from A to B what are all the
different ways to do that if if you did
sort of I don't know what they're called
you know some kind of tracing graph
thing where you keep the labels of how
you got
to how you got that equivalent so to
speak I mean again I'll let colors get
to the end but in a minute I can show an
example of this of how this works
internally within the Category 3
framework because it is just kind of
graph rewriting internally
oh sorry no all I was going to say was
so in relation to your previous slightly
more philosophical question the way I
okay so you'll write in a sense that you
know and you always need some kind of
meta logic right you need that there's
somewhere there's some ambient thing in
which you need to immerse the rules uh
which is you know in this case you're
immersing the rules of mathematics in
inside WL which is you know the thing in
which you then enact the the
substitutions
um I would
um I would say it's a little bit
different from the entailment cone stuff
um because I mean this is one of the
reasons why
yeah okay for me this is one of the
appealing features of category theory is
that it gets around one of these what in
my opinion is a kind of core
philosophical confusion which is so
suppose you want to
um
you know okay
suppose you want to generate a multi-way
system for you know for for group Theory
right what would that mean so there are
many different levels in which you could
do that one is you could say well let's
start with let's do the universal
algebra thing right let's start with the
axioms of a group and let's take some
statements as the initial condition
let's apply those axioms as rewrite
rules we generate kind of true theorems
in you know in Universal algebraic group
Theory that's one code
another thing you could do is you could
say well let's start with an element
let's have the rewriting rules be
applications of generators
um and then the equivalence function is
the application of relations and that's
then you've got a different kind of a
more semantic multi-way system that
effectively solves the word problem and
then you brought an you've even got
another level higher which is you could
say well let's have each state vertex be
a group and then let's have each
morphism B have each you know Evolution
Edge be it be a homomorphism of groups
um and then each you know each cyclic
Edge beer be an isomorphism of groups
and then we've got some multi-way system
which represents kind of all the the
space of all possible groups these are
all different kind of possible multi-way
strands and let me just understand this
one the one you just drew here no no but
the the the feature of category theory
is that it removes this distinction they
are all the same thing and so so the
point is that what's happening with
these rewrites is not akin to
application of axioms in the you know in
the entailment code sense it's it's akin
to application of generators right what
you've got is an underlying Digraph
which is the quiver and then the
elements of that quiver freely generate
some category degree although they they
you know they they free by applying
transitive closure they freely generate
some some you know more complicated
graph and then the category is just what
you get when you say well let's just
apply equivalences between all the
multi-agents
yeah I think I understand but let me try
that on the thing that you had from that
wolfen model evolution in some sense
okay one version of how you make a group
is
every node is a different word
in this case the nodes are actually the
elements of the group
and the different words correspond to
different edges
no so so so in some sense you want to
ignore you want to ignore the existence
of the objects entirely right you just
want to focus on the morphisms so for
the case of a group The Analog would be
you you've got a quiver which is which
is just given by the collection of all
elements of that you know of the
generators of that group yep
um then you've then you freely generate
some you know that then then the graph
that you get by transitive closure
corresponds to all possible kind of
combinations of those group elements and
then the relations are the things that
then apply equivalences between those
multi-edges yes
I agree
how do we see that here
well so in this case you could you could
treat this as like a three element group
right
yeah
and I could read off could I read off
equivalences between words by looking at
which edges if I were to label the edges
they would be labeled by words and any
two edges that go between the same nodes
are equivalent words is that correct
is there
um
what
where I think I'm still a little bit
fuzzy here but but Jonathan's point
about the
what category theory is doing
Carlos would you mind terribly if I if I
just quickly shared for like two minutes
and then I maybe this will work yeah I
was gonna say sorry sorry and you say
that again I I missed I missed the sound
Jonathan was just asking if he can share
maybe it won't help but just take your
time I mean right okay
uh hopefully you can see a notebook
um okay so if I do something like this
uh let's do H goes from X to W and I
goes from W to the c or something
okay so there's a quiver right that's
just a digraph
yeah
uh so now if I were to take
that
I generate this
so now effectively what's going on
internally is just a rewrite rule that's
added a an identity morphism to each
object and that anytime we've got you
know a pair of morphisms that share a
common domain and codomain we just add
an additional Edge between them so
because of the you know because because
there are two routes from X to Z uh
we've got two different labeled edges
here right that you can do I compose H
or you can do G compose f
right right
um and so then what you're doing here is
this is essentially a transitive closure
of nothing above exactly exactly and so
then we can say commutativity equations
and all that that's doing is it's saying
well let's find let's find all the
multi-edges and then let's find the
minimal set of algebraic relations that
would be necessary to force all those
multi edges to collapse and so then I
can take this I can say
those so now commutative diagram returns
true and if I say reduce labeled graph
those will get canonicalized to a single
thing and so but then the point is if I
if I extended this if I had say I don't
know F2 goes from uh Z I don't know
um
let me see if I can do this
fly let's do y to q and then let's have
H2 goes from P to Q or something does
that make any sense
uh it's probably the only way around
I don't know maybe that's sensible maybe
as well let's see but anyway okay so
there's a let's get rid of that
equivalence
but so there's an example of a more
complicated thing
equations but but it's just the same
thing that's going on internally and so
the point is that by by setting up the
by setting up the underlying graph
structure by setting up the quiver in
the right way you effectively have fine
grain control over what element so if if
you think of the morphisms here as being
elements of some algebraic structure you
know like elements of a group or a ring
or something then by changing the quiver
structure in particular changing which
morphisms are you know which of the
edges are are sort of which share
vertices and which don't you can change
which elements of that algebraic
structure are allowed to be composed
with each other and which aren't and so
then you know then the sets of possible
relations is that you know or the you
know the set of sensible relations in
that algebraic structure is the set of
possible equivalences that you can
Define between the multi-edges
yes
um and so as the and the point is you
know the reason one of the reasons why
category theory is so powerful is
because there are these universality
theorems that effectively say we can
represent any algebraic structure in
this way
the category theory is a strict
generalization of essentially all of
algebra
walk me through what that means in
practice
uh sure so so the point is that if you
know if you were to take you know if you
were to if you were if you wanted to
represent a group or something so you
know if you're just generating a free
group then you want all you know all
elements should be able to be composed
with each other so you would construct a
quiver in which all edges uh share you
know have at least one shared vertex
between
um you know but in in their in their
Source on their target yep and I would
generate so then the the corresponding
category would have the structure of a
free group
okay
so I mean so the I mean in this in the
simplest case so so the the canonical
way to do that in category theory is
just to have one L is to have a one
element category oh you know one object
category
but so
if just like one can enumerate Axiom
systems in the standard kind of symbolic
you know equational logic type thing
right can one enumerate
what's the corresponding enumeration of
categories
uh well it's so you so you can you can
just enumerate directed graphs
um and then as I say that then you have
some Freedom so then each one of those
generates a free category like that so
this is kind of this is the free
category generated from this quiver yep
and then the point is that you then you
have some freedom to make additional
restrictions by you know by
equivalencing certain multi-edges so you
would you would start by by effectively
enumerating Quivers and then you would
enumerate you know subsets of these of
these additional algebraic axioms okay
so let's say when you make clever
Quivers you you take transitive closures
you get categories yep then
can you kind of scan over the different
directed graphs and say what is what's
the name of the algebraic object that
corresponds to I mean you're going to
get out of the domain of ones which
people have talked about but I'm just
sort of curious if you were to enumerate
because with Axiom systems for example
it isn't particularly natural that is
the Axiom systems that turn out to have
been used in practice are not low-lying
Axiom systems I understand what I'm
saying so maybe that's not true for the
category case maybe the I mean if we
just enumerated directed graphs would we
scan over the commonly studied algebraic
types of systems or would we end up even
very quickly getting things which
haven't been studied and finding that
there's just an obscure case that has
been studied you you wouldn't you would
very quickly find things that haven't
been studied so this would be how you'd
represent something like a group
um as an example right so
uh oh so in this particular case of
course we've got two elements never mind
but okay so
um this is very poorly laid out because
it's not the the the categorical
framework is not very good at laying
these things out yet but um but
effectively you know this this is what
you would see right so you've got so so
say you've got four oh no secretary say
you've got three morphisms that all
connect one object so you've got an
energy and an H so now you can compose
those together
um and and any any pair of them can be
composed together because they all share
the same objects yep
um and so you get associativity because
it's from from the fact that it's a
category you get identity from the fact
that it's a category and if you
additionally impose the property that
this diagram commutes then every one of
these that then you know every one of
these edges has effectively an inverse
and so you get a group
um and so so a group is a one element
cat is is a is a one element uh category
in which every morphism has an inverse
has a left and right inverse so Jonathan
for the fact there are three morphisms
that you've drawn here
this is the same this is a three element
group if I drew another morphism that
would be a Four Element so how do you
distinguish in this view uh I think for
the benefit of Stephen as well how do
you distinguish different three element
groups
uh yeah I mean that's a that's an
interesting question right so then you
like
I I think a hardcore category theorist
would say that
you know groups are the same no no no no
no no the the distinguishing feature is
only in the algebraic you know the
algebraic properties of what things are
equivalenced
um determining equivalences between
those algebraic axioms is non-trivial
which is why I'm a bit hedging but but I
think that that is the you know
philosophically that is the distinction
yeah so but also outside of category
Theory question those equivalences
between the algebraic
I mean is that something doesn't isn't
category blind to that doesn't it look
in terms of category theory that all n
element groups are the same no really I
mean not not it depends on what level
um but but not not as a rule so the the
point is that so all three element
groups would have the same underlying
quiver
so but if we take the if we take the
free category generated by that quiver
there are many different possible you
know this commutativity equations list
will not in general be be empty so
there'll be many possible choices of
equivalences between the course and each
one of those choices corresponds to a
different three element group yeah as I
say that you you if you actually try and
do this stuff algorithmically which most
category theorists don't run into this
problem of how do you determine when two
you know two equational Axiom systems
are really the same thing
um and that's not the problem I I've
managed to solve but um uh but at least
it's undecidable in general
one of two equational hexim system is
the same
hopelessly undecidable right because
it's it's similar to but but
undecidability is fine if you because
you can still Define a semi-decision
procedure the problem is it's hard even
to Define precisely like
you know
for example one thing you might do is
ask are all their models the same
but even that no that's hopeless too
because because no exactly but like so
if you it's okay to to take a simpler
case right imagine if you go back to
your you know minimal accommodizations
of Boolean algebra if you just show
someone uh you know two accidents you
know two Axiom systems for Boolean
algebra that but you know for instance
potentially Define different operators
right one of them defines chapter spoke
but you know one of them defines right
you know and or not and not yeah um then
and you ask are these axiomassizing the
same algebraic Theory it's very hard to
figure out how you pose that as a you
know as a as a decision question it's
clearly a well-posed mathematical
question well let's think about that for
a second because that question is quite
interesting because that question
are two programs the same yeah yeah
anyway call us let me hand the sharing
back to you no I mean I want to do I
want to do it I'm not going to move on
from that question Stephen because and
thanks Jonathan
Carlos Carlos just start showing your
screen oh yes yes yes yes
you can see that right okay yes go ahead
what are you going to say Carlos yeah I
was going to say that um
first of all Jonathan
showed for the
with your functions there is precisely
the sort of the the philosophy that I
have for this General case what we're
trying to do here we're trying to push
above the the quiver structure right so
we want to in the same way that you have
a quiver and and you can generate but as
Stephen says it's transitive closure
um we want to say well actually
translated closure corresponds
particularly to this rewrite rule here
and um and taking uh Quivers is already
a choice because it's you know directed
graphs in this in this kind of way so
when we want to do a particular
application of this packlet and this
kind of functionality is saying well
what if we take all kinds of hypographs
as potential diagrams to begin with like
the equivalent of a quiver and what if
we generalize Transit exposure to other
kinds of closure and that's where the
fish or the you know the I have this
example at the very end which uses this
um basically this is a
tetride which is like a tetrahedron
without one of the faces that rewrites
the missing phase with a triangle right
so everything here is an unordered
um and and so you can have similar
situations where you rewrite and you get
similar phenomena right and so the point
just to summarize because that's really
the point of this application that I was
going to show is precisely take what
Jonathan has beautifully done with that
with that functionality and try to
generalize the quiver
um initial structure and the idea of
associative closure
um and and extend it and use sort of
hypographs as a template for generality
which I think I think is the right
generality that we want
um and then discover things and the
thing is we did discover ReDiscover this
fish thing this semi-hippo and to me
that gives me I mean this is the operats
for example it's also quite natural to
to encode operad which is the sort of
multi-category composition thing
um and and the fish in particular right
so this to me is signaling that this
this is this potential for Discovery as
Stephen was saying that we might get
into Uncharted Territory but also charge
the territory that has been spotted and
this this equation in the in the fish
this Axiom was was first listed in the
50s 40s and 50s and people have known
about this but it's very obscure almost
nobody nobody has heard of this uh but
it has been known and it was
rediscovered as an instance of this so
so and it was described by saying I will
start with instead of Quivers I'll start
with something like this triangular
hypergraphs and instead of composing by
transex closure my equivalent of Transit
closure is this sort of fish uh smash it
right when you get a fish then you just
put you know head to tail triangle and
and that's sort of the summary that I
wanted to close it there maybe we can
move on to the very interesting okay my
question here would be so one question
is
if you enumerate buy Quivers so to speak
yeah and you ask a question
what do those different directed graphs
what algebraic theories could be
represented by those different directed
graphs that would be an interesting
thing to know whether the ones that have
been studied are ones that correspond to
the simplest directed graphs because it
isn't true in Axiom systems the ones
that have been studied are pretty not
low-lying
I think I think that may be a less
interesting question than it sounds I
mean I I agree it sounds like an
interesting question in the abstract but
um effectively all algebraic structures
that have been studied in kind of
classical what we might call classical
algebra pre-category Theory algebra
corresponds to one object cases of more
General categories so so the the group
case just now is the you know groups are
a one element groupoid but there are
also analogs I think you know a a monad
is a one element monoid
um you know a a a a ring is a one is a
one element ringoid Etc yeah yeah so the
so the the the the sort of the names
alphabetic structures will always end up
corresponding to the sort of the one the
single vertex yes the things generated
by single vertex equivalents yes I would
I would add though I I completely agree
but I would add that
generation here I think it becomes more
relevant when you take the perspective
of finding this phenomena as something
that is a rewrite phenomenon because
formally you can say if you can write it
as universal algebra
there's this CRM that you alluded to
Jonathan that tells you that you can
actually
um model this in in categories right but
I think what is what's interesting here
is that if you if you want to generalize
for example you wouldn't think of what
is called semi-hepoids right um in in
this in this context where where you
know they are modeled with this fish or
this uh sort of three Arrow pattern uh
like the zigzag pattern that I call uh I
mean those things are somehow primitive
in the sense that you're you're taking
that particular quiver model and you're
saying the composition the transitive
culture works this way particularly and
and so it's a matter of okay so that
that is that is semi-hivoice okay that's
that particular thing so what what are
other
um hypographs or graphs uh that can they
can you know take you to some
interesting algebraic land and that's
the that's the core question that I have
in the background which is I think quite
related to what Stephen was saying if I
understood correctly that if you if you
try and in fact my Approach is going to
be to enumerate uh to some degree up to
some sizes all the possible small
hypographs that's part of the motivation
to actually do sort of more
classification taxonomy or small hyper
graphs to be able to actually chart this
sort of compositional structures that
you end up with when you start when you
start with different sort of um sort of
template uh diagrams right because we
know that you know you start with the
digraphs or Quivers you have you have
categories and groups and group points
when you have symmetry or maybe
undirected and all these kinds of things
um those
um are examples of uh an otherwise you
know uh question that is parameterized
by what you take as your Motif right
what do you take as your sort of
starting Motif which is summarized in
this kind of rewrite rules right
um so yeah so I think it's a very
interesting question and that's part of
it okay so hold on the let's let's see
what will happen if you do this so I
mean you know for example there's
decidability questions given a
particular
how will
you get sort of empirical evidence of
undecidability in one of these systems
I mean it's basically the existence of
an infinite path in the equivalence
between two two things which will
ultimately be equivalent will have an
unboundedly long path to get from one to
the other I would suppose actually it
doesn't it doesn't have to be of
unbounded length
um you you can you can have a you can
have an infinite collection of Parts all
of bounded length would be would be the
case where the word problem is
undecidable
right a path of unbounded length would
correspond to an infinite length word
whereas the case for the undecibility of
the word problem is the case where you
have finite length words but the number
of algebraic Transformations necessary
to to equate them is infinite yeah right
you have a finite length apart you know
you have two finite length paths but it
would require kind of infinite
multi-edge equivalences to translate
between them by the way columns like I
would say I think this I do I do think
this is really really cool and so it I
mean if if I if I understand what if I'm
understanding what you're doing
correctly so the the the case of the the
sort of the graph rewrite version of the
of um of you know for a sensitivity that
you showed above which is you know the
or the graph rewrite form of of
transitive closure this is really just
this is this is what this is encoding
what in conventional algebra is just the
application of left and right generators
right if if you if you do that in graph
rewriting terms this is what you get the
point that you're making if I understand
correctly is that if you consider more
General so you're kind of generalizing
what it means to apply a generator
particularly if you consider a high
charity algebra you know some higherity
structure then you could apply left
generators right generators you know up
generators down generators or whatever
yeah
apologies yeah exactly right and in
addition to applying it you know
individual generators you could also
apply you know you you could have you
know you could apply one thing on one
thing up and one thing left and and so
on and so you get just a more General
class of you know what what ultimately
just typography writing structures but
then the argument is that that all the
same things that you would do in
ordinary category Theory to discover
algebraic theories you can do in the
more General context which exactly and
discover potentially different things or
Okay so let's take it another way let's
say you're doing hypergraphy writing and
that's your primary interest right in a
sense you can view these things as an
algebraitization of of hypography
writing early yes
so one of the questions there would be
you know we've got hypography writing I
mean
you know
when we think about the physics project
for example
I have long claimed that hypergraphs are
merely one representation of what's
going on and that they might perfectly
well be an algebraic representation of
what's going on where the thing just
looks like some some complicated Algebra
I don't know maybe it's an algebra
people have seen before
but my question is you know if I pick up
a random typography writing process
does this provide a way okay several
questions one do you get sort of exactly
solvable typography writing models out
of this because they correspond to some
algebraically reducible thing
two is there a given an arbitrary
typography writing system is there some
kind of algebraitization that this
implies
okay yeah I have I think interesting
correctly uh the answer is no in general
but that's interesting because you get I
mean these are examples in which you do
get
um I understand I mean right in the case
of cellular automata for example yeah
there was a hunt for multiple years of
other cellular automata that are exactly
solvable for example using relations and
number theory for instance there are
rather trivial ones that use additivity
and are exactly solvable but nothing was
ever found that would use I don't know
some weird Mobius inversion formula or
something to be solvable
so the question is is that in
hypergraphs
is the before you get out of the
atmosphere into where you can't breathe
anymore and it's all irreducible yeah
are there still other forms other than
the trivial things are there sort of
exactly solvable cases like in in
partial differential equations for
instance we know they're integral
systems which are a sparse set between
sort of linear systems and the
non-linear Mass
yeah but so the question is oh there's
similar things here
well the hope is the Hope is that there
are and in part in part the reason why I
included this tetroit example in the end
is because this is a very
very likely example and but we we still
have to actually okay so maybe let me
flesh out this point because I think it
will make clear what I mean so this
particular system
um has so the algebra that comes out of
this has been has been studied by uh but
someone called the badacharya Messner
there's a paper from the 19 from 1990
that that discovered this Association
scheme and and they basically postulated
the the operation is like this you have
a like a tetrahedron with three
triangles and then you basically rewrite
the missing one uh and
and the idea is okay so what are the is
this so everyone knows that this is not
associative in the conventional sense
it's a ternary operation that is not
none associated in the conventional
sense
um so the question is does it satisfy
some form of associativity right that's
that's a basic question so
um the first thing you might want to
spot is can I find so in my perspective
in this is a rewrite perspective you say
well can I find an initial State you
know I hook up an interesting iograph
interesting looking hypograph so that
yeah apply the rewrite Rule and I get
something like Confluence like before so
you can actually do it in quite a
trivial way so you can this is basically
this looks like a mess but that's
basically a tetrahedron where you're
placing a tetrahedra on each of the
three phases right so so surely enough
you apply the rule and you get obviously
a Confluence system because you're doing
you know collapsing that each of the
horns independently and showing how you
get to a single place and if I had all
the labels those would be different
labels there are different different
sequences now when you actually uh look
at what the what what you are doing in
the in the algebraic expression
effectively what's happening is that
you're doing you know you have a you
have a bracket that takes three three
um inputs right so effectively what
you've done is you've done ABC
and then you've done
whatever one two three
and then you've done XYZ right so so in
some sense you're not you've not done
anything
um interesting
um in in algebraic right so indeed you
this Confluence property actually is
connected to the fact that you can take
any order of operations there you can
operate ABC or XYZ and then the other
and so on right so it it basically just
says well if you were to to make this
into a traditional algebraic system you
have some freedom in in the order in the
sequence of of
Contracting brackets or operating your
elements and ultimately there's a single
there's a single output right so this in
this case this property hasn't spotted
an interesting equational axis right so
my my hunch is that I didn't find a
clever enough
um initial hypograph so that's where the
enumeration or the systematic yeah right
right that's the only way to find it out
you will exactly one will never be
clever enough to do this one exactly the
numeration is the right way to do it but
but the question I'm asking I mean I'm
just trying to understand the strategy
here you know
the several strategic endpoints here it
seems to me
one would be can I answer can I answer a
second question no go ahead yeah the
second question
um I feel is it was part of the I mean
it's a bit late and I had another
notebook where where I I expanded a
little bit on that point but there's a
very obvious way to algebraize uh a a
rewrite a typographic system in fact let
me just bring up the notebook yeah
please so so this is the perspective of
hyper Network Theory basically right so
um where I'm calling hyper Network
Theory I haven't heard that said in many
places
um so the the standard story I'm just
gonna recovery briefly standard stories
you have graphs in which you know your
adjacency uh property basically says you
know is one connected to three by a song
two some intermediary two and we all
know that the adjacency Matrix of uh of
a graph has the algebra of the adjacency
Matrix uh of the graph has something to
do with paths in the graph right so so
so basically what I demonstrate here is
I mean by the way this is using the same
backlit function so this is not a
particular case
um so what I want to do here is okay let
me actually show the algebraic part
first so I take adjacency hyper Matrix
uh you know I take the the square a
times a and sure enough uh if my initial
state is this I should get something
that looks like you know the two paths
that I can connect with length two right
so the the demonstration here is okay we
know the algebra this is traditional uh
you know algebraicraft Theory but the
question is can I make that into a fully
rewrite construction and the answer is
simply very simply yes you can do this
sort of one pass rewriting which which
means that you're basically just adding
the single application step but all at
the same time right so that particular
rewrite algorithm corresponds exactly to
taking the square of the adjacency
Matrix of course that's a very important
when you look at the square of the of
the Matrix algebraically that's a very
special Constructor it's a squared
basically the only thing you can do if
you only give me one element then I have
a binary operation but if you look at
the rewrite side and this is what
excites me this is a very special
construction that you've done you could
have done a million of other things that
don't have an immediate interpretation
algebraically but nonetheless perfectly
well defined for for the rewrite
perspective right so there is a clear
embedding so to speak of the algebraic
description of of graphs in the in the
rewrite world you just have to specify
rewrite procedures that implement the
the algebraic structure so so conversely
you can
you can find some particular algebraic
Behavior sorry a particular rewriting
behavior on on this side I might
actually get some algebraic behavior
when I when I do the adjacency sort of
dualization of the of that well I mean
my expectation would be General graph
rewriting is vastly more General than
anything you can capture with algebra
than anybody's ever seen before it looks
like that definitely right yeah so I
mean
and then the issue is as I was saying
before when do you get out of the
atmosphere so to speak when do you get
to the point where everything's
irreducible you can no longer say
anything and is there a waypoint like
integral integral differential equations
for example where there is an exactly
solvable case that is intermediate
between the rather trivial cases that
one already knew and the cases where one
can't do anything and that would be I my
guess would be that there are such
situations with hypographs and that will
be kind of interesting to find because
it would provide one with a you know
another model system that's non-trivial
I mean I you know spent too many times
I've ended up with a grid graph as you
know this or that example of what
happens with hypographs right that's
just one I mean from a strategic point
of view that'll be one thing that would
be nice to have is a you know in at
least in the history of statistical
physics
exactly solvable systems like the
two-dimensionalizing model for example
have been very useful
and so you know having exactly solvable
hypergraph model would be a very useful
thing
I think yeah um I mean what do you mean
by exactly soluble here in this context
oh I don't know what I mean I don't know
nobody ever knows what they mean by that
it basically means you can compute
things without having to just
computationally irreducibly run stuff I
see in the two-dimensionalizing model
you can compute all the correlation
functions
um just sort of by using algebraic
formulas right whereas in 3D we only
know how to do it by doing simulations
right I would say my initial answer to
that would be that it's precisely the
kind of the motivation of this entire
effort which is that if you you we do
have some criteria of what rewrite
systems are interesting and what retro
systems do uh the kind of things that
we're interested in particular
um the the Confluence with you know
different labels and to spot algebraic
accents and things like that so the idea
would be a hope would be that once you
start charting this unfamiliar territory
it doesn't have to be huge it's just you
know unfamiliar it's small but
unfamiliar
um then you you have this
criteria of okay in this context of
categories or groups or Rings or
whatever this particular property that
I'm familiar with like associativity or
distributively correspond to this
particular uh rewrite property most
commonly uh confidence and so on and so
the idea is to go go exploring and then
have those as some kind of
um templates that you can compare and
and then try to because surely you will
find things that are just very you know
wild and they don't do anything no right
right so I mean yeah right there are
ones where you will be able to say
things and where you will be able to map
them on to sort of some existing
mathematical knowledge and others where
you will not and so finding which ones
are I mean it is non-trivial to find out
whether they map onto existing
mathematical knowledge unless this is a
really great representation
sort of knowing that the thing has some
I mean that's why it was non-trivial to
solve the two-dimensionalizing model or
something to map it from being an
amazing model to being something
involving I forget what hypergeometric
functions or something like that which
is what the solution comes out in terms
of I mean that that um anyway
so yeah
um
okay so so I I suspect that what you're
referring to as exact solubility is
precisely what Carlos is doing here with
these with this algebra
algebraicization of these rewrite rules
right so you know that that effectively
if you can take a hypograph and you can
represent a hypography writing system
and you can represent uh the equivalent
structure like the you know like for the
case of associativity here purely in
terms of kind of um Elementary algebraic
operations on say it's adjacency hyper
Matrix then I I suspect that's kind of
the analog of what you're yeah
that is of a fundamentally different
character to something like exact
solvability in a cellular automated or
indeed in an Isaac model because this is
exact solvability of the equivalencing
not exact solvability of the evolution
yep well fair enough so because with a
cellular automaton the equivalence
function is Trivial I mean you don't
really worry about it for the case of a
deterministic CA so what so when the the
algebraic work that you're referencing
Stephen is is stuff where people are
saying okay predict can I can I have
some formula that tells me in 100 steps
what the ca registers yeah yeah that's
right whereas the um that's not really a
concept that appears you know if you
consider the algebra algebraitization of
uh hypergrapher writing systems that's
not really a concept that exists you
don't have an algebra a concept of like
show me what the words of this algebraic
structure will look like after a hundred
generator applications that's not really
a question that people ask well if
you've got these pictures that show
going from you know one state to another
state to another state
right right my point is that even if
there were some notion of exact
solubility it's it's unclear the terms
in which one would Express that because
because conventional algebraic
structures certainly don't do that
um so yeah I think it's easy to Define
at the level of the state equivalence
function
um I think but I think there's also
something else going on at the level of
the state Evolution function which has
no obvious analog
to that point be our third point I'm
supposed to go to something completely
different but go ahead just a few more
minutes and I really got to go the yeah
um let me add one one extra thing which
I mean I think ties up things nicely
um which is this question of whether
some of these systems map onto existing
mathematical systems or non-algebraic
structures and things like that this is
actually something that we have been
thinking about uh at The Institute
recently I mean in the last I don't know
a couple of months where uh actually the
reason why I started why we started
developing this hypograph stuff is
precisely because it allows us to draw
diagrams that are extremely General and
they can encode all sorts of formal
systems and we you know I had fun some
afternoon just translating all kinds of
SK combinator stuff into the hypography
right rules so I could you know convince
myself that these are sort of a template
that that you can you can use to to
quite quite generally Express things and
so one of the questions that long-term
questions that that are Beyond this
particular search for behavior of
rewrites is that you know exactly what
you mentioned earlier Stephen how do you
say how do you determine that two things
are are in fact the same or what we
called it in this context how how do you
decide that something is emulating
something else right how do you decide
that that system is actually an
important problem exactly that's an
important and not I mean nobody knows
really when you say this register
machine can be emulated by this turing
machine nobody has a good sense of what
the distance is of a of a some kind of
distance metric of that emulation
which is essentially a rule space
distance of some kind yeah we don't know
how that works exactly so it's one of
the main reasons why I pushed a little
bit to go into these typographic
approach is that hypographs have a quite
a you know convenient natural community
structure and so everything can be
expressed as some form of label
hypograph system then you have quite a
bit of Machinery to actually you know
you take a if if you know SK combination
is a particular typography right and
Boolean out there is a particular
hypergraph rule right in the beginning
when I joined the Institute then you can
clearly see that you know these if these
are expressed as hyper rewrite rules
under the including then you can just
apply some you know hyper Matrix entropy
measure to determine uh you know
distances between these things and you
have some preliminary approach to to the
to the difference between the two
systems and you find obviously that one
is you know much more uh parsimonious
and the other is is much longer in
Computing in Computing time right in the
computer in steps so so yeah so it's
definitely uh one of the advantages well
I mean the question really is we already
know like in Wolfram language you know
tree based rewriting
we already know
admitting the fact that in that case
code and data are a little bit different
I mean they can be represented as the
same thing but they are applied
differently
and I don't know whether that works it
does work somewhat differently and
that's why this whole question that we
were discussing earlier about
hypergraphy writing rules versus
hypographs themselves and Nick was kind
of showing some differences between the
way to think about hypergraph
Transformations and individual
hypographs but in a sense
you know we already have one universal
representation which is just symbolic
expressions
but that's a case where we have a bit of
fancy footwork because we have things
like patterns versus non-pattern
expressions and so on and
maybe with hypergraphs there's less
fancy footwork to do
um I think there may very well be uh
go ahead do you mean that they are
somehow more parsimonious by but I don't
know they don't have as much look in the
case of transformation rules on symbolic
Expressions you have to have the concept
of pattern variables for example right
um and you have to have also some sense
in which
well the rules aren't necessarily
different than the Expressions
themselves I mean I had a whole
discussion about that in the metamath
project
um that you can apply rules to rules and
all this kind of thing
um
you surely still have to have some
notion of effectively which you know
which hyper vertices you're universally
quantifying over which which are treated
as constants in your rewrite rules right
that doesn't get you out of the patent
problem maybe I'm not sure about that
because I think you could decorate
I mean you could probably do this insane
with pattern variables but I mean you
can like label a thing as a as a
constant by decorating it with sort of
some number of you know different
numbers of of um
uh self-loops
that type of thing I mean it's a bit of
a hack but maybe you can do exactly the
same thing with patent variables I'm not
sure
yeah I mean the the analog of saying
that I can yeah I can just wrap a
pattern in arbitrarily many heads
yeah that's probably right
yeah that's probably right yeah so I
mean the the question then is
in I think the basic point is everything
has to have an evaluator at some point
without an evaluator nothing happens
claim I mean in other words whether that
evaluator is saying hypergus have
transformed or whether it's saying
expressions are transformed
it's
well and this is what's confusing about
the mathematical case versus the physics
case you know in physics the application
of the evaluator is time
you know measures time whereas in
mathematics you merely discuss
equivalences independent of time
in some sense
well I think I think the the my approach
to the quote-unquote emulation problem
that we mentioned before was precisely
to try to make mathematical equivalents
more time like unintended Maybe
so yes so that was part of the part of
the game I guess that you were trying to
make a mathematical equivalence into
something that is in in a sort of
possible structure or or in some kind of
rewrite
um flow and then you can take time like
measures or or you know
um yeah like Observer like measures I
mean that you have like this listen I've
now just run over two meetings so I
really have to get going here but this
was interesting and um uh a good I you
know I hadn't had a chance to check in
on any of this stuff for a really long
time and so this was um this was really
uh good to see Jonathan any lost
comments that you might have
no no I think this is really cool thank
you very much for your comments uh
Jonathan it was very helpful thanks yeah
all right we'll we'll see you guys soon
and thanks to folks who've been joining
us on the live stream I have got to run
off see you later bye bye guys